[Música]
el colmo de la estupidez es aprender lo
que luego hay que olvidar
con esta cita de erasmo de rotterdam
quiero comenzar hoy
quiero que reflexiones porque uso esta
cita todos vosotros que habéis tenido
que tenéis en algún momento una
experiencia educativa
vivimos los momentos muy importantes
convulsos y yo creo que tenemos retos
por delante yo creo que hay cuatro retos
fundamentales
primero la globalización la
globalización que sigue avanzando sus
procesos de deslocalización de la
producción los distintos lugares de la
cadena de valor
esa globalización de producción no
siempre va acompañada de globalización
de personas y uno de los retos que
tenemos como sociedad es la atracción de
talento de talento femenino
principalmente
además nuestra sociedad envejece poco a
poco pero sin que nos demos cuenta está
cambiando la estructura de nuestra
social de nuestro grupo de una manera
que la humanidad nunca lo ha visto no se
ha visto antes y tendremos que afrontar
retos sociales y económicos de cómo nos
organizamos de una manera distinta por
último la tecnología
quizás la siguiente revolución
tecnológica relacionada con los robots y
la inteligencia artificial
va a traer retos muy importantes sobre
todo en el empleo
y tendremos que ser muy cuidadosos de
cómo protegemos a los más vulnerables
ante estos cambios
bien ahora que os he puesto en situación
quisiera enseñar un gráfico en este
gráfico veis en el eje de abajo
cuanto han progresado los sistemas
educativos en términos de años de
escolarización en los últimos 50 años
cada punto es un país cada punto naranja
y en el eje de arriba veis cuánto han
progresado desde el punto de vista
económico desde entonces como veis no
podemos encontrar una relación entre
todos estos puntos la recta que trata de
asociarlos es plana y los puntos están
agrupados de manera caótica no hay
patrones
muchos de vosotros pensaréis bueno pues
esto es la prueba de que invertir en
educación no merece la pena esto no nos
da resultados
es mejor que pensemos en invertir
nuestro tiempo y nuestro dinero en otras
cosas
pero por suerte los más optimistas ya
sabéis que esto no es así
porque cuando en vez de comparar años en
la escuela comparamos el aprendizaje
real lo que aprenden los alumnos en la
escuela
y lo relacionamos con el progreso de las
sociedades ahí vemos una relación mucho
más clara mucho más fuerte
veis los países se agrupan la recta se
inclina y los puntos están todos mucho
más cerca de la recta
de esto concluimos una idea una idea muy
sencilla pero muy valiosa
que es que no se trata necesariamente de
más sino de lo que se trata es de mejor
no se trata de tener más títulos de
obtener
más pruebas de ser capaz de certificar
ciertas cosas lo que se trata es lo que
aprendemos por el camino
de lo que se trata en definitiva es del
aprendizaje
para que me estoy refiriendo cuando
hablo de aprendizaje qué es lo que
quiero decir me estoy refiriendo a ser
capaz de recitar un poema de memoria
o me estoy refiriendo a saber lo que
significa una señal de fa
o incluso memorizar una fórmula o un
mapa con ríos y montañas
bueno pues me refiero en parte a esto
pero me refiero a mucho más
me refiero a todo lo que hacemos
alrededor de estos conceptos como
razonamos con ellos como los
interpretamos como formulamos qué es lo
que desarrollamos a través de ellos esto
en educación es lo que llamamos las
competencias
y en este sentido os quiero hacer una
pregunta yo quiero preguntaros si
queréis si estamos construyendo una
sociedad orientada al aprendizaje al
aprendizaje en este sentido
a mí me gustaría tratar de responder con
dos ejemplos
esto es lo que me encontré hace poco al
entrar en una librería
vi la estantería y no pudo evitar sacar
el móvil
la imagen es muy fuerte son unos libros
de texto bueno algunos estarán en papel
en los centros otros en tabletas pero es
el material fundamental para el
aprendizaje en la escuela y en la
universidad
y el mensaje que lanza es demoledor en
mi opinión de lo que se trata aquí es de
aprobar
esto es de lo que se trata
no se trata de lo que hacemos por el
camino no de lo que se trata es si somos
capaces de aprobar el examen de aprobar
curso
para mí es una suerte de perversión del
propósito de aprendizaje en una sociedad
moderna como la nuestra
y no es una cosa aislada ni espontánea
no haya caído como una gota esto revela
algunas grietas profundas de nuestro
modelo de aprendizaje
algunas grietas que en el fondo nos
muestran que tenemos pequeñas enfermedad
es una pequeña enfermedad con el
aprendizaje para mí el síntoma más
importante de que tenemos una pequeña
enfermedad con el aprendizaje que
tenemos que cuidar es la repetición de
curso
en euskadi el 25 por ciento de los
alumnos cuando llegan al final de la
etapa obligatoria han repetido al menos
una vez sino dos veces
es un número muy alto es un número muy
alto cuando lo comparamos con los
sistemas educativos de nuestro entorno
en la ocde o en la unión europea donde
repiten un 10 un 11 por ciento pero
también cuando lo comparamos con otra
suerte información
esos mismos alumnos que repiten que
repiten curso cuando pasan pruebas de
aprendizaje competencial pruebas
internacionales como pisa pero también
nuestras pruebas de aprendizaje las
evaluaciones diagnóstico que realiza el
gobierno vasco
muchos de ellos demuestran que aprenden
así que de alguna manera estamos
aplicando una política educativa errónea
porque pues gracias a la investigación
desarrollado en los últimos 30 años
sabemos que la repetición no funciona
que en la mayoría de los casos no
arregla la situación incluso en algunos
lo agrava
no sólo eso para los resultados que nos
da es tremendamente cara es una
inversión muy cara porque es una
inversión de un año de dos años de
escolarización más para nada es más sin
mejor
y lo que es peor en euskadi la
repetición es injusta porque afecta al
alumnado que viene que proviene de
orígenes socioeconómicos más
desfavorecidos independientemente de su
capacidad para aprender
pero entonces porque estamos aplicando
está política
estamos aplicando esta política por la
ley por cómo es la regulación los
decretos no
todos los sistemas educativos tienen
normas sobre cuando los alumnos deben
repetir cursos
todos las tienen problemas no es la
revolución la regulación el problema es
la cultura lo que tenemos aquí dentro
sobre lo que es el aprendizaje
es la cultura porque pensamos
confundimos la diferencia entre aprobar
y aprender o quien no habrá oído nunca
se merece repetir así aprenderá
lo que estamos haciendo con estos
alumnos es decirles vuelva usted a la
casilla de salida y vuelva a andar todo
el camino pero quizás lo que tenemos que
pensar es que necesitan algo distinto
segundo ejemplo que os quiero contar
esta foto va a ser realidad en las
próximas semanas
es la foto de una oferta de empleo
público que se ha convocado
que en mitad de junio seleccionaremos a
cientos de docentes que serán los
docentes del futuro el sistema educativo
y lo que les vamos a pedir es muy
sencillo tendrán que repetir un temario
un largo temario que apenas ha variado
en los últimos 25 o 30 años y nada más
lo que hacemos con los alumnos se lo
pedimos a los docentes del futuro os
dais cuenta
pero el problema
es que la educación ha cambiado
la educación ha cambiado porque la
educación hace 40-50 años trataba de dar
respuestas colectivas iguales para todos
desde un prisma individual el del
docente el portador único del contenido
pero hoy es mucho más difícil la
sociedad demanda mucho más y el alumnado
es mucho más diverso por eso se
necesitan dar respuestas
individualizadas para ser adaptadas a
cada alumno desde un prisma no
individual sino mucho mayor y para eso
además de dominar estos contenidos
necesitamos docentes que tengan mucho
más en su mochila
necesitamos docentes que tengan
capacidad de liderazgo capacidad de
empatía que muestren un compromiso un
fuerte compromiso social
como veis el sistema
tiene cierta perversión
y tenemos que salir de ahí pero no los
profesores y los alumnos también
vosotros alumnos de la universidad
quiero preguntaros qué es lo que
recordáis cuando estudiaste jce para
vuestro último examen
recordáis el contenido que aprendiste
qué es lo que os marcó o quizás os marcó
el propósito de superar una traba en un
momento de presión de gestionar vuestro
tiempo en un poco espacio de tiempo de
preparar vuestro trabajo vuestro examen
con compañeros y de cómo os comunicas
teis con ellos de cómo gestionar stage
el conflicto a eso es a lo que me
refiero como aprendizaje a eso hacia
dónde dice dónde debemos ir
muchos pensaréis que bueno que el camino
no está claro que lo que debemos
aprender como sociedad es discutible y
yo pienso que no
yo pienso que no porque en la sociedad
del conocimiento el mercado laboral y la
demanda de una sociedad democrática con
valores ciudadanos nos demandan
exactamente lo mismo que son personas
capaces de aprender de tener sentido
crítico de tener valores individuales y
colectivos que sepan trabajar en grupo
que sepan superarse
que sepan participar que sepan
implicarse a eso nos referimos con el
aprendizaje ya eso me refiero cuando
hablo de qué es lo que rodea el
contenido las competencias
pero no podemos negar que esto no es
fácil no es un camino transitable de
aquí allí que todos podemos hacer
para que recorrer este camino tenemos
que mirar la problemática en toda su
complejidad no vale mirar con las patas
del problema y tratar de poner un parche
aquí porque quizás sale una hernia ya ni
mirar a la trompa del problema oa los
colmillos hace falta mirar al problema
en su conjunto de cara mirar al elefante
tal y como es mirar al concepto mismo de
aprendizaje sin engañarnos sin miedo
antes de marcharme os quiero dar algunas
buenas noticias y una pequeña esperanza
os presentó ayer al kennedy gerard
kennedy fue elegido ministro de
educación de la provincia de ontario en
canadá cuya capital es toronto
cuando llegó cuando llegó él con su
equipo se encontró una situación muy
complicada un profesorado en las
escuelas altamente desmotivado una falta
de confianza pública en la educación por
parte de la ciudadanía
los resultados en caída con problemas de
absentismo y aprendizaje
pues bien fueron ambiciosos
y se propusieron mirar al elefante desde
una perspectiva integral tratar de
transformarlo en su conjunto y no poner
parches
si logramos nuestros objetivos lo
conseguimos
irá todo bien y si no lo conseguimos
abandonaremos pero esa fue su meta
el resultado es una de las mayores
experiencias de transformación educativa
reciente en un país como el nuestro
aquí algunas claves en lo que
consiguieron y de cómo lo hicieron
un grupo de líderes de personas
comprometidas con el cambio que fijaron
pocas prioridades pero muy claras y que
fueron midiendo a lo largo del camino
involucraron a los agentes clave a los
agentes clave de la comunidad educativa
y les fueron preguntando estamos yendo
por el buen camino si por aquí no por
allá
además se tomaron el tiempo y fueron
inteligentes de generar nuevos espacios
y tiempos para que los centros y los
profesionales empezarán a hablar entre
sí empezaron a hablar una conversación
cambiando el prisma individual del
aprendizaje por una visión más colectiva
además libraron la batalla a nivel
público
fueron a los medios explicaron lo que
querían hacer no tuvieron miedo en
defenderlo y no se dejaron caer
por las inercias por esas trampas
culturales que unos se van encontrando
por las lógicas de la política en la que
muchas veces el bombardeo no te deja
pensar la dirección que llevas
tomaron el riesgo y asumieron que su
meta era una
el impacto fue muy grande la confianza
se restableció los resultados mejoraron
y el gran público la sociedad empezó de
nuevo a confiar en las escuelas
y esto es muy importante
pero con lo que yo quiero que os quedéis
no es solo con que los poderes públicos
pueden hacer mucho el cambio en el
aprendizaje es tan importante que no lo
podemos dejar solo a los poderes
públicos tenéis que decidirlo también
vosotros padres madres alumnos
profesores
si estáis comprometidas con esta idea
que es más importante aprender que
aprobar tenéis que lanzar osa por ella y
exigir la muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]